sich die frage wann ist die inhaltliche
grenze dieses jahres erreicht
kitsch kommerz nicht ernstzunehmende
kunst
so schnitten gegner über musicals für
sie ist klar die theatralischen chance
in der einem als garage für die masse
doch viele musicals haben andere
ambitionen
das belgischen spektakel 14 18
wenn wir opfer des ersten weltkriegs
gedenken
die bombastische inszenierung fokussiert
auf persönliche schicksale auf menschen
die ihre träume auf dem schlachtfeld
begraben müssen
krieg und entertainment geht das
zusammen
wir fragen dieter bartetzko kultur
redakteur bei der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung und spezialist für
das vordergründig so leichtgewichtige
unterhaltungsgeschäft musical ist wenn
man es als kunst ernst nimmt genau wie
jede andere kunst berechtigt sich eines
jeden themas anzunehmen
man sollte um des themas willen um der
moralischen erkenntnis werden so wollen
will kein mittel auch der unterhaltung
verschmähen und ganzen blicken kann
ein gutes beispiel dafür das musical
miss saigon über die tragödie des
vietnamkriegs seit mai weg des im
londoner westend wieder emotionen
und auch der zweite weltkrieg diente
schon als vorlage für ein musical
ghetto in der inszenierung von peter
zadek wurde 1984 uraufgeführt ein stück
das die wahre geschichte einer jüdischen
variete gruppe erzählt die im ghetto
villa um ihr leben spielte vor der
premiere habe der es proteste auf dem
friedhof spiele man kann musical so der
tenor
als die musik dann lief und als sie
wieder gesungen wurden des musicals
waren es die lieder die sozusagen
geöffnet haben das publikum für das
grauen das dann sich entwickelt hat und
man kann nicht sagen dass da
moralvorstellungen verletzt worden wären
bis
kann man das düstere kammerspiel
überhaupt in die gängige musical reihe
einordnen ganz gerührt wenn dann noch
mal hält der vergleich stand ich denke
ja weil jemand war also ein ganz großer
des theaters der das musical ernst
genommen der die großen voraussetzungen
die in dieser gattung liegen
aufgegriffen hat und verwendet hat also
das war sozusagen der adelsschlag für
das musical samt bloß zu bildende
mitbekommen
mit schmissigem auftritt das publikum
erreichen und berühren das sei die
stärke der sparte
doch für viele geht noch immer
unterhaltung gleich banalität auch west
side story habe nicht die kraft etwas zu
bewirken
obwohl genau das der anspruch des
theaters sein sollte so die kritiker
sagen sind wirklich vorteile und der
unwillen sich einzulassen auf diese
kunstform wenn sie schauen welche
reaktionen westside story bei seiner
uraufführung hervorgerufen hat wie
wirklich ein
tausende im laufe der zeit sich dann
gefragt haben was ist eigentlich bei uns
in der bronx was ist mit den straßen
denn wie behandeln wir die migranten
dann ist das ein unterschied und ich
denke damit verbietet sich so
gedankenlos dinge abzuurteilen
dieter bartetzko ist sich sicher
musicals sind keine zerstreuung sondern
eine eigenständige kunstform auch für
die auseinandersetzung mit gewichtigen
themen wie den ersten weltkrieg